un filósofo llamado tales de mileto
logró descubrir la altura de una de las
pirámides de egipto con solo medir la
sombra de la pirámide habría sido
difícil hacerlo con una regla no crees
te explicaré cómo lo hizo tales observó
que a determinada hora del día la sombra
de una persona es igual a su estatura
así que espero ese momento del día y
tomó la medida de la sombra de la
pirámide la cual era justo la medida de
su altura real pero porque funcionó
tales lo explica en su teorema esto
sucedió porque se forman triángulos
semejantes observa qué ocurre si ponemos
nuestras figuras juntas la altura de la
pirámide y la de la persona son
paralelas entre ellas y forman
triángulos respecto al suelo y a la
proyección de los rayos del sol
tenemos este triángulo grande y este más
pequeño
quitemos las sombras y los objetos para
dejar solo los triángulos si colocamos
más líneas paralelas a distancias
iguales descubrimos que los triángulos
que se forman van creciendo de manera
proporcional esto quiere decir que la
distancia ha aumentado un lado y del
otro en la misma manera al doble al
triple y así sucesivamente
de esta manera tales de mileto aportó
este nuevo conocimiento al tema de
semejanza de triángulos en donde cada
vez que una línea paralela corta un
triángulo este será semejante al primero
y sus medidas serán proporcionales ahora
podrás calcular la altura de cualquier
objeto sólo asegúrate de formar una
relación proporcional con triángulos
semejantes te invito a descubrirlo